Why should the idea of sex
outside be exciting?
Given how awkward, scratchy, sandy or
muddy it can be on a beach, halfway up a hillside
or in the shady bushes of a park – compared
with the comfort of cotton sheets and a sprung
mattress?
As so often with sex, the pleasure is psychological,
not physical.  It's a thought that is turning us on and the exciting idea
is that we can at last lose our normal self-consciousness and inhibition and take our sexuality
out into the world without embarrassment.
Shame normally profoundly colours how we perceive our own sexuality.
From early adolescence we take great care to shield our sexual sides from others.
They would have no interest, they might be sickened.
We reserve our naked selves strictly for the bedroom, in the dark, late at night.
The Biblical story of the expulsion of Adam and Eve from the Garden of Eden
reflects this embarrassment.
It isn't just a quaint piece of theology, it's a universal account of
how we've travelled painfully from uninhibited toddlerhood to embarrassed adulthood.
But with a lover to lend us new buoyancy,
we are liable to feel more acceptable to ourselves again.
Because they are representative of the normally brutal outer world
have found us desirable.  We acquire a background hope.
That we might be able to do away with the normal punishing rules.
Once again enjoy the favours of loving innocence.
To suggest we go outside to have sex is a touching provocation,
a minor dare to imagine that society won't always have to be hostile or indifferent.
To our vulnerable sexual selves
and by extension to our existence more generally.
In truth, the sex can't do more than express a hope,
that the short blissful encounter in the park or behind the supermarket
is at least evidence of a defiant Utopian faith
that we can, with our lovers support, perhaps turn the wider world into what it so seldom is...
... our home.